[Music]
don't be late news oh that's for you oh
god please all right you know what you
need one you're getting one for
Christmas she does have a wooden apple
one yeah I never never watch you're not
getting anything for Christmas
what the [ __ ] you guys watch out for
something else submitted by tips it's
amazing
a white figured out a way to make sure
her husband comes home by 9:00 p.m. I
already know the answer it is some
poetry if you combine IBM what the [ __ ]
kind of relationship is that Oh longer
stranger get off of me uh women had that
power though because a guy can't do that
we can't dangle the dog and maybe she's
an angel in I think girls always forget
how much power they have because the
reason why he's not home is this is open
and then the bottom part is closed if
you reverse that mm-hmm
and in the bottom you know what it's
funny item coming home every day five
this guy is just [ __ ] the wrong clam
is open yeah you know why it's closed
give me the articles you know Wyatt
closes because you guys are [ __ ]
stupid and you say [ __ ] to make it close
when the beginning when you sell all the
right [ __ ] that [ __ ] was wide open
come on Ian this is the part we never
liked that Michael do you agree with
Michael as well you know what like when
you first said the article headline I
was thinking oh you know she pauses call
us of an 8:30 every single day to remind
talk about that to like you that is
getting at the relationship it wasn't me
yeah and we didn't [ __ ] with me to take
care no it wasn't it wasn't any of those
things it was sure I'm down with
whatever I'm not like the other girl and
it turns out you guys aren't like the
other girls exactly the
say shut the [ __ ] up both of you [ __ ]
it's me and David what gate will be
[ __ ] all day yeah why don't you it
seems make you [ __ ] love each other I
will tell you this right now that would
be a very very horrible sight to see
that would be holding the wall who takes
turns like therapy boy get it out get it
out hey let me say the article freeze I
need to cleanse my brain he deals with
real goodness I'm sorry is about okay so
this girl she was visiting her
girlfriend and Shanghai oh and then
that's when she realized that this is
like odd thing by the front of the store
she was like where'd that and then
that's what she said like oh I installed
this card reader to make sure that my
husband comes home on time like a
employee [ __ ] card scanner yes oh my
god her husband works at a it's this
thing right here her husband works at an
Internet company and so apparently
recently the company has been asking him
to do a lot of overtime to she was like
ah not happening in this house so she
was like if you can do this at work you
can do this at home so that's why she's
in street and sold it and then there's
like rules here and it says that if the
husband comes home by 9:00 p.m. he's
rewarded with a warm dinner and the
company of his lovely wife without
having to do the dishes but if he comes
home up to 30 minutes later he is fined
with 100 yuan or 15 dollars and if he's
more than 30 minutes late he has to put
in a whole day of house tours in the
weekend question may I ask this know
does she work ah I don't know does she
have kids I don't know olive leave if
you ain't got none of that [ __ ] you
don't get the state any [ __ ]
stipulation to me
yep so [ __ ] that [ __ ] you would attacks
me for coming home late for bringing the
cheddar that allows you to stay have a
home if you were taking care of
kids that's your job I understand I get
it you need help with the chores you
need to help with the kids and I'm
coming in all late drunk and [ __ ] I get
it if you stand at home you ain't doing
[ __ ] you don't get to say [ __ ] [ __ ]
to me I'm working [ __ ] yes I agree
well that should I hate that that's
annoying [ __ ] Asian girls I mean if
she afraid that because of this overtime
that like he may be having an affair
maybe yeah like her friend ended up
posting this photo I just showed you on
Weibo and that's how it went viral it's
very uh what's it called condescending
it's super condescending I don't like
that [ __ ] at all if you can't manage
your own [ __ ] I'm going to manage you
the way they do at work you don't talk
to me like that [ __ ] I know I want to
avoid Charlie Charlie Munoz yeah Charlie
okay Charlie good yeah but apparently
the husband has been coming home [ __ ]
school clearer than 9:00 p.m. you
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] we can't judge
I mean it's just it doesn't work with us
it is a vibe or gel with us so I can't
judge that's okay is such a legitimate
reason for being late I mean that's so
sad I was thinking to all Mike Hughes
working yeah what do you expect I lost
my job with now you're a loser it's like
before you said Paul maybe what the wife
is dealing today she only sees him when
she's sleeping they don't have a
relationship for something like if he's
coming home at like 10:00 or 11:00 every
night this is already in bed
she said what we're not even together
anymore so maybe you just doesn't have
enough of a backbone to put his foot
down at work this is like bucket I'm
gonna do something we don't know if this
guy's a [ __ ] or if he's really bringing
home the cheddar or if he's out cheating
like we don't know the actual stuff may
even page for sure though for the wife's
even dared had a [ __ ] that's true the
device not actually in the house the
whole wall where that thing would be the
holders on the whole thing is [ __ ] on
I forget check it out too
I left what the [ __ ] you and I'll bust
nuts on the [ __ ] envelope on the
[ __ ] letter oh that's what I think of
it yeah yeah you just turned on do you
buy were you know I'm a goal it's a path
of much portal get turned on and then
come back downstairs to this
that's not of work why don't you just
watch you right then in there and then
you start done or I feel like you could
like take a show on it that's even more
of a [ __ ] you no no I don't like
ultimatums like I don't like that [ __ ]
you want talk to your partner that way
what the [ __ ] you're such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you better be cheating dude like
you better be cheating on the [ __ ] yes
not the Dicky he's uh he's enabling that
behavior though yeah going on time you
earlier
dude like he smells like straight-up hey
hey hey hey hey slow down you don't talk
to me that way I think I've said it
[ __ ]
yeah go stuff my day have you been given
all tomatoes no I'd never be with
somebody to give me an ultimatum
I think it that it should even come out
your [ __ ] mouth God like there's not
even emotional tie to that but let's say
matter when we first started dating she
comes up and she goes okay when we start
dating though so now on this is when you
have to talk to me I'm a that's [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] go die as I walk out yeah
because at that point too is like I'm
not even emotion attached you can put if
she put stipulations on me now be even
worse especially cuz we already have
like that trust that you don't even have
to do that to me
I don't ask you about your [ __ ] you
don't ask me about my [ __ ] and you don't
even have to worry because I'm away the
whole what are you doing out clubbing
like [ __ ] right now
or you hear about some situations where
like the person puts like an ultimatum
on the other person saying like it's
either me or your friend or me or your
mom or mom or your hey it's not educated
why'd you go already automatic in your
head me or your mom I gotta roll with
this way she gave me life yeah like I
can't met you huh me or your friend I've
known the doctor I understand you my
stepmom she might gave that to my dad he
was like see there me or your daughter
my dad was like [ __ ] you like it keeps
my daughter laelia means I don't know
but there are people commenting saying
things like his lifeless work at HR or
this is too much you're stripping away
his freedom no one as [ __ ] did you get
the card reader from the past on the
Chinese office depot or that chef oh yes
[ __ ] that she thinks she is dude
there were others that got inspired
saying hey hired those are the crazy
ladies stay away from that's why you
Asian men are not you that's like Asian
thanks for a non-asian one but I've
dated quite around and I just like the
Korean ladies now because culturally it
works for me
and unlike cultural preservation if I'd
like I said this before if the women
that I used to like a lot if they were
willing to learn the language which
there was one girl who I really really
liked and the she just was not willing
to learn the language and she was no
other that's [ __ ] funny I would learn
to speak your [ __ ] language but you
won't do it for me you didn't know Jenna
I know she was speaking the bleep funny
my uncle he fell in love with a Filipino
girl in dental school
she spoke perfect Mandarin and Taiwanese
and they were madly in love she brought
her home and my grandma said no no no no
jungle Asian oh man and then she lit it
and then I don't know this my personal
opinion started you guys watch this but
I think he married not out of love but
out of commitment and loyalty to my
grandma see that's weird because my mom
was okay she goes that's why they just
had this big Korean because she just
wants to be able to speak to her and
have a conversation so even if let's say
they have a dispute it's not me getting
in the middle and talking between them
or if they want to have a conversation I
had to constantly translate so I see
even see it with like with my cousin
like the the my aunt is a very very
funny person hilarious right but they
will never ever get to know each other
because she refuses to learn the
language or she doesn't try to you know
I'm not dogging her on it I mean
obviously it's very difficult but if
they want that relationship to happen
they have to be able to talk to each
other as I keep telling Casey let me
learn Cantonese and him and your parents
keep saying no it's a dead language
don't learn it but I'm like but that's
your culture it's like when you speak
like with your family and like I want to
be able to connect with your family to
like you can always take a class I know
just work yeah so yeah but like I needed
I need to talk to someone to practice
excuses and that's when I tell you have
these two why not only
Oh Julia Andy joy IQ barely sweetener do
you speak better than me oh yeah I suck
I guess I can use them but it's just
that every time bring it up they're
always like no don't do it learn
Mandarin because I'll understand it
that's what I keep saying but I'm like
but you know Mandarin like I tell people
you don't know Mandarin hurts like I
want to be able to teach your kid both
of our languages that's a tricky part
with Chinese there's so many different
ones so I already don't have cultural
preservation between my mom and my dad
they're both Chinese my mom's Tony's my
debts Cantonese and the culture is
already a little bit different and then
so I'm confused in the middle too
so I like [ __ ] it I'm a confused no more
just Mexican I wasn't going on xing-ke
news fans hope you guys like exact
episode remember to follow our personal
social media and of course if you want
to watch more videos like should go
where to go you suckers right up there
[Music]